bonjour à tous bienvenue donc pour cette
édition spéciale
on va aller à bagdad en quelques
instants à retrouver un des français qui
fait partie de la délégation du pape
françois pour 7 me pour cet événement
historique
on est en plateau également avec jean
marie guénois bonjour jean mallot un
spécialiste des religions et au figaro
et georges malbrunot grand reporter au
service international et spécialiste du
moyen-orient jean marie guénois écrit
notamment jusqu'où ira françois georges
malbrunot a écrit trois livres au moins
sur l'irak
sans parler de tous les livres qui est
écrit sur le moyen-orient je vous donne
l'embarras du choix vous pouvez
retrouver tout ce qu'ils ont déjà écrit
sur cette visite spéciale du pape
françois dans le dans le figaro et bien
sûr dans le chat que vincent le noble va
mettre juste l'article qui va le mettre
dans le chat qui est juste à côté de ce
player et dans sur lequel vous pouvez
poser toutes vos questions on a les
meilleurs spécialistes mais avant de
dire revenir avec vous sur voir les
premières images éventuelle de bagdad et
d'entendre benoît camurat à bagdad
on écoute justement le pack françois
voici ce qu'il disait juste avant de
s'envoler ce matin depuis rome fiumicino
bingo comme pèlerine comme pellegrino
pénitente et pauline préval signant le
parton de réconciliation pour un idiot
et freddy terrorisme tels qu'eads a dit
à la consommation dans les cours et la
voirie jaune de la vérité les zooms au
travail comme pellegrino des patchs et
mégots commun pellegrinelli patcher
cadets fraternitat
animateur de décider vip rarissime et
des familles n'a réussi mais un gros nid
fratelli la soirée les diablos ne
s'était pas réunie chez unica famille
ont souligné blake christiane ah oui
cristiani soumagne ah oui
pour lui il popolo décident ils décident
ikanos offert total total tutti fratelli
tout y aura vivo ni la bourse therabel
dtf élites comme et pelegrino 10 paires
ans et voilà donc ces mots prononcés par
le pape françois il ya 48 heures avant
donc de s'envoler ce matin on verra
peut-être les images du décollage depuis
rome
on va retrouver tout de suite à bagdad
six il nous entend benoît camurat
bonjour benoît re bonjour de soru vous
êtes le responsable directeur général du
jeu d'une ong française qui s'appelle
fraternité en irak vous venez donc au
secours des minorités sur place et vous
faites partie de la délégation française
de la délégation donc dans le voyage du
pape vous
vous avez pu arriver à bagdad donc
depuis depuis 48 heures quelle est
l'ambiance quelle est la situation sur
place
moins d'une heure maintenant de
l'arrivée du pape françois je dirais que
c'est un mélange d'euphorie
d'effervescence et en même temps d'une
certaine tension parce que vous savez
qu'il ya un couvre-feu à cause du
coronavirus donc les rues sont vides
il ya un grand dispositif de sécurité
qui s'est mis en place tant autour de
l'aéroport que de l'église sayidat al
najat notre dame du perpétuel secours
il y avait eu 48 morts à la toussaint
2010 qui s'est mis en place donc la
ville et au fond étonnamment calme en ce
moment et en même temps il ya des
explosions de joie comme à cet endroit
où je me trouve dans cette rue il ya
quelques heures
il ya une très grande fête avec de la
musique des jeunes qui chantait qui
dansaient l'arrivée du pape françois
donne vraiment beaucoup de joie aux
irakiens c'est un très grand cadeau pour
eux et donc il ya ce mélange entre eau
fleury et on sent qu'on est un peu en
attente comme si le temps s'était
suspendu avant que le pape françois
n'arrive à bagdad avant on va continuer
à suivre ça avec vous merci benoît pour
ses premières précisions jean-marie si
on a choisi de faire une spéciale
aujourd'hui à un peu avant l'arrivée du
pape c'est parce que on fait toujours
des spéciales au monde de grands
événements et c'est un évènement
considérable
aucun pape ne s'est rendu en irak et
françois est en train va sans doute
réussir là où ses prédécesseurs ont
échoué
oui il ya eu un projet avec jean paul 2
c'était en décembre 99 la veille du
grand jubilé de l'an 2000
jean paul ii voulait se rendre à ur où
le pape ira samedi matin ours est donc
là selon la tradition la ville où
abraham serait né et il avait sauvé jean
paul 2,7 ce dessin de réunir la les
religions et de poser un acte que va
poser effectivement françois françois
effectivement trépigne cela fait plus de
six ans qu'il veut se rendre en irak
qu'il avait déjà projeté lors d'un
voyage précédent
une étape surprise à erbil où l'avion
s'est un peu sur la route se serait
posée
pour quelques heures pour parce que son
souci c'est vraiment d'aller encourager
il a parlé on l'a vu à l'instant il veut
consoler ce peuple veut et sait très
bien que la situation est très difficile
à résoudre mais en tout cas il veut tout
faire pour apporter une sorte de baume
au coeur aux chrétiens évidemment
irakien en premier lieu mais à tous les
iraniens irakiens c'est bien l'esprit
dans lequel le pape seront là bas est
effectivement de ce point de vue il a
osé envers et contre tout et envers ses
conseillers contre ses conseillers qui
était très réservé sur la faisabilité et
les conditions de sécurité
évidemment de sécurité tout court et des
sanitaires
en l'occurrence puisqu'on rappelle que
c'est quand même la première fois qu'il
quitte le vatican depuis le confinement
depuis la crise du corner oui le dernier
voyage remonte à novembre décembre 99
c'était au japon et est il ay là il n'a
pas bougé depuis quasiment pas il est
dûment vacciner il a il est là il après
tout ce qu'il fallait pour partir là bas
il prend un véritable risque un risque
personnel sanitaire et un risque
politique mais ça c'est tout à fait
assumée et il ne va pas là bas pour
faire un parcours parfait il va là bas
pour d'abord apporté un soulagement
apporté une consolation dans une
perspective chrétienne ouvert à tous
c'est vraiment son souci et on verra
ensuite ce qui se passera c'est un peu
aussi la loi commune de ses voyages
pontificaux qui sont à la fois des
voyages officiels mais le pape mais
certains chefs d'état mais n'est pas ou
plus un simple prise dans la république
c'est un chef religieux il ya une
dimension transcendantale dans tous ses
voyages
et là c'est un pari ouvert d'aidé de
contribuer à la stabilisation
parce qu'on est loin du compte la
stabilisation de l'irak justement sur
cette stabilisation est sûre cette
situation actuellement en irak georges
c'est quand même un énorme défi
à la sécurité est-ce que ce voyage au
regard de la situation qui est celle de
l'irak depuis bientôt une vingtaine
d'années maintenant
c'était c'était réaliste c'était
raisonnable
est ce que un voyage en sécurité
aujourd'hui en irak c'est possible pour
quelqu'un comme le tout cas c'est un
véritable défi sécuritaire qu'il auquel
il est il est confronté parce que il y a
plusieurs menaces si elle émeut la
menace des djihadistes de dèche qui même
s'ils n'ont plus de khalifa
territoriales ont des cellules dormantes
dans un certain nombre de lieux que
jean-paul que françois va survoler et
puis il ya l'autre menace sécuritaire
qui vient d'une autre composante qu'est
ce qu'on appelle les milices chiites
irakiennes est plutôt pro iranienne qui
se ont été menaçants ces dernières
semaines qui ont attaqué une base dans
le nord du pays où il ya des américains
qui sont stationnés alors là la bonne
nouvelle c'est justement celle qui avait
attaqué cette base a décrété une sorte
de trêve pendant la visite papale donc
lui il ya un vrai puis oui et puis il ya
un vrai risque qu'il ya un vrai risque
sécuritaire c'est quand même
c'est un casse-tête à la fois
logistiques et sécuritaires mais c'est
vrai juste pour revenir à ce que
jean-marie disait il ya un très grand
attachement du vatican je me souviens
mois dès les années 95 j'allais en irak
monseigneur etchegaray envoyé par le
pape alé voir saddam hussein pour à
l'époque essayait d'envoyer des messages
aussi l'irak était soumis à un embargo
implacable et donc il ya eu ensuite en
2003 la guerre les diplomates du saint
siège du vatican sont restés là-bas
pendant les trois semaines de
bombardements donc il ya un vrai
attachement du vdev relance et
d'ailleurs oui il y avait un français il
y avait il ya un vrai attachement du
vatican envers ce peuple qui est
meurtrie depuis 40 ans et donc il ya eu
effectivement d'occasions ratées de 1999
est là aujourd'hui le pape a dit j'y
vais et je crois qu'il faut saluer
d'ailleurs les irakiens et y compris le
gouvernement irakien qui voit à travers
il ya un élément qui est important on va
en parler pr manquantes on évoquera le
l'itinéraire jeu franc le pape a atterri
à bagdad repart à bagdad
toutes ces étapes il revient à bagdad il
replace l'état central très
affaibli par les confessions justement
par le l'immixtion de ceux de ceux des
confessions depuis 2003 au centre de son
voyage
ça ça fait du bien ça rassure le
gouvernement irakien et ça rassure aussi
les chrétiens irakiens qui savent
d'expérience
hélas mauvaise expérience depuis 2003
qu'un état faible et bien ça laisse les
milices chiites sunnites radical s'en
prendre aux minorités et à être victime
comme ils l'ont été victime collatérale
de ces guerres civiles qui a eu entre
2000 sur les chrétiens que ils sont
divisés par trois en nombre depuis
quasiment depuis quasiment enfin
certains chiffres les plus optimistes on
a 400 mille aujourd'hui 1 million 500
médias il ya 20 ans alors sur un pays
qui fait 20 millions aujourd'hui 140
millions donc si c'est une c'est une
communauté qui est en pleine hémorragie
qui suivit les manger on va justement
retourner devant un de ses lieux
emblématiques de la présence des
chrétiens en irak c'est devant donc dans
cette église tenus par les dominicains à
bagdad où se trouvent
benoît camurat benoît justement est ce
que au regard de ce que vient de dire
george est ce que la laine avec les
attaques est ce que cette tension elle
et elle est palpable et en particulier
dans la communauté chrétienne quel est
le sentiment qu'il y a quel est le
sentiment qui domine chez les chrétiens
aujourd'hui les chrétiens à bagdad
on imagine la joie mais est ce que il ya
sept ans au crâne de cette crainte
d'attentats l'écouté il ya évidemment un
traumatisme très grand les chrétiens ont
subi entre 2003 et 2014 d enlèvement des
assassinats des attentats comme celui de
ses dettes et nadja qui a fait 48 morts
des attaques contre des étudiants qui
allait de qaraqosh à mossoul qui étaient
ciblés contre les chrétiens
donc cette communauté elle est
traumatisée et lorsqu'on demande
aujourd'hui aux chrétiens de quoi ils
ont peur or dit il n'y a pas eu
d'enlèvement récemment s'est rien passé
contre les chrétiens de quoi est ce que
vous avez peur et 10 on a encore peur de
ce qui s'est passé contre nous notamment
à ces détails la jat c'est à dire que
les terroristes malheureusement ont
réussi à instiller la peur
dans dans le coeur et dans dans la
mémoire des chrétiens donc l'enjeu est
effectivement de cette visite c'est
effectivement de réussir à tourner la
page de ses années noires et c'est pour
ça que je dirais qu'il ya une très très
grande attente de la part de la
communauté chrétienne que là on est dans
une situation où cette visite suscite
beaucoup de joie mais effectivement il
ya comme le disait très bien georges
malbrunot un certain nombre
d'incertitudes sur cet état qui est
encore assez faible et cette grande
attente de la part des chrétiens à
l'occasion de cette visite est le patron
soit en parlera
c'est la question de la citoyenneté
c'est à dire que les chrétiens
souhaitent être reconnus comme citoyens
de manière réelle ils le sont à travers
leurs papiers mais ils veulent que cela
se traduise de manière concrète
quand la justice s'est prononcée quand
un chrétien veut avoir accès à des
postes de fonctionnaires par exemple et
c'est vraiment cet accès à une
citoyenneté réelle
qu'attendent les chrétiens et bien sûr
une stabilisation de la situation et
comme ils le disent tous la paix la paix
et la sécurité
on n'entend quasiment rien que les
oiseaux voler autour des 2 benoît non on
vous entend bien ne vous inquiétez pas
attendez par contre ce que ce qui est
frappant c'est le silence que qu'on
semble entendre autour de vous il ya des
mesures extrêmement drastiques
on le disait
au niveau sécuritaire mais il ya des
mesures drastiques au niveau également
sanitaire même en irak un georges que
subit de plein fouet aussi la pandémie
elle est même actuellement soumise à un
pic de cette pandémie
comme dans la plupart des pays du
moyen-orient la distanciation social est
impossible parce qu'on est en orient et
donc il ya une chaleur
lire est donc les gens se rencontrent à
simplement c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
vendredi c'est le jour férié
il ya traditionnellement moins musulmans
dans les rues mais mais mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya un risque sanitaire aussi le
vendredi dans un pays musulman
majoritairement musulman c'est
l'équivalent du dimanche qu'on est dans
un pays occidental ou majoritairement
chrétien je salue zygo kriss kross qui
nous rejoignent en ce moment est
justement vous avez bien fait ou vous
commentez et vous posez vos questions on
a les meilleurs spécialistes avec nous
on a quelqu'un sur place c'est
formidable donc effectivement on est là
pour dialoguer kriss kross nous dit
pourquoi j'ai l'impression que le pape a
trop longtemps ignoré la souffrance des
chrétiens d'orient
est ce que le pape a trop longtemps
ignoré la souffrance des chrétiens
d'orient jean-marie que non ça c'est pas
possible de dire cela parce que le
vatican donc je parlais de jean paul ii
à l'heure mais benoît 16 par exemple
avait organisé un synode spécial sur le
moyen-orient avant c'était un de ses
derniers grands textes avant sa
démission 2013 pour défendre justement
la citoyenneté des chrétiens d'orient
en tant que chrétien et en tant que
citoyens de toutes les sociétés où ils
ne peuvent pas être citoyen et françois
dans son style a continué le même combat
cela dit françois a ouvert une nouvelle
branche politique en quelque sorte de la
géopolitique spirituel du vatican avec
une main tendue à l'islam et c'est ce
qui donne l'impression qu'il défendrait
- les chrétiens d'orient ce qui est faux
lui il est dans l'idée que d'ailleurs
soutenu par la diplomatie du vatican
depuis longtemps qu'il est nécessaire de
dialoguer avec l'islam
pour éviter justement des conflits dans
l'église devra tout à perdre à les
chrétiens les premiers donc ça donne
l'impression qu'ils défendraient
- des chrétiens d'orient mais je peux
vous dire que ils sont tout autant
soutenu y compris financièrement
moralement par par le par le pape
françois ne peut pas dire cela est ce
que le pape françois fait avec pour les
chrétiens d'orient ce qui a été fait au
temps du communisme par la politique
d'un grand diplomate du vatican qui
s'appelait carniel casaroli ce qu'on
appelait lost politique c'est à dire
vous et des grands sourires on faisait
des concessions mais justement pour
pouvoir protéger les chrétiens qui était
dans ces pays où il était percé dans le
paf rend ça va plus loin sur la question
de l'islam
il est convaincu que l'avenir de
l'humanité est dans la culture de la
rencontre c'est son grand thème c'est
pas seulement un mot c'est à la fois
philosophique et théologique et
spirituelle la dernière encyclique
fratelli tout y rappelle ce message de
fraternité universelle à la françois
d'assise d'ailleurs il faut que les
hommes absolument ont plus à gagner à
s'entendre cas se battent à se combattre
et il est il ce n'est pas un calcul
c'est pas un calcul politique en se
disant si je tends la main à l'islam je
vais protéger mais chrétien extra pas du
tout il a une vision beaucoup plus
ouverte et de long terme qui est
débattue y compris à l'intérieur de
l'église ne va pas tout seul cette
vision certains pensent qu'on devrait
davantage protéger les chrétiens
d'orient
mais lui est convaincu à terme et à long
terme que c'est la fraternité
universelle qui l'emportera merci pour
ces premières précisions on va reprendre
encore justement vos
vos commentaires rigaud qui nous dit ce
pape est décidément très courageux et
igo nous dit qu'il ne faut pas oublier
les anges les ans je devrais de cette
visite selon lui sous selon elle c'est
un pseudo à une vraie cette visite a une
vraie mission spirituelle alors
justement on va retourner que benoît
camurat à bagdad
quel est le programme aujourd'hui
quel va être le programme du pape
françois quand il va donc quand son
avion va atterrir dit si maintenant une
pomme un peu plus un peu moins de 40
minutes
eh bien d'abord y avoir un accueil
officiel à l'aéroport puis la délégation
va se rendre à la présidence de la
république où sera aussi présent le
premier ministre en fait qui va
accueillir le président à l'aéroport
puis la délégation se rend à la
présidence de la république
il ya une rencontre avec les autorités
civiles irakiennes durera aussi des
représentants qu'ils aient dit qu'ils
seront là tout à l'heure à la présidence
de la république dont quelques
présidents balram saleh et le premier
ministre moustapha al khazali et puis le
saint-père réunir dans cette église qui
s'appelle sayidat al najat notre dame du
perpétuel secours qui est un lieu très
très fort très poignant puisque c'est là
que durant la messe de la toussaint le
30 octobre 2010 des terroristes sont
entrés et ont tué 48 chrétiens et une
dizaine de membres des forces de
sécurité durant une prise d'otage qui a
duré quatre heures et et là il va
rencontrer en fait les religieux les
membres du clergé
il y aura aussi des personnes
handicapées qui seront là il y aura
quelques personnes qui ont survécu à cet
attentat qui sont aujourd'hui en bonne
santé des membres aussi de la famille de
personnes qui sont mortes dans cet
attentat et je crois qu'il va avoir
on peut en être voilà c'est pas une
surprise desmoudt très fort tout à
l'heure à cette date and that pour
qualifier cette violence qui
instrumentalisent la religion à des fins
politiques ou comme l'ont fait ces
terroristes d'al qaïda a pris c'était
lui qui avait fait cette attaque contre
cet état de la jat donc voilà l'étape de
bagdad demain matin il décolle benoît on
va revenir aux étapes demain ça peut
être faire un arrêt si je puis dire à
bagdad on va avoir d'ailleurs les images
des préparatifs
à l'aéroport international de bagdad
donc avant l'arrivée du pape françois et
avant que la terrisse le vol d'alitalia
sur cet aspect on sait qu'ils avaient
été à l'origine de cet attentat c'était
cet âge là à l'époque donc c'était un
attentat qui avait lieu et s'il en est
et si je vais faire le juste peut-être
rapidement ce qui nous reste
anormalement que cinq minutes des bandas
pts 5 minutes en plus mais pas tellement
plus parce qu'il ya les autres
programmes
derrière mais sur l'enjeu de bagdad
on l'a dit c'est un enjeu politique de
consolider l'état irakien également est
également celle enjeu symbolique c'est
d'arriver au coeur au coeur de ceux au
coeur de ce pays pour le pape oui et
cette première étape pas dans cette
église est très importante parce que il
commence vraiment parce que la visite
aux autorités politiques c'est habituel
ça fait partie du protocole habituel les
voyages mais commencer le voyage dans
cette église sur les traces du sang
versé de ces martyrs parce qu'ils sont
martyrs pour l'église catholique
c'est très important on va regarder la
carte justement des étapes que doit
justement honorer le pape françois donc
bagdad
aujourd'hui et demain nadjaf et our en
chaldée jean marie c'est assez
symbolique ou en chaldée parce que c'est
là que jean paul 2 justement voulait
aller en 1990 et surtout là où selon la
tradition abraham le père des croyants
donc perdre isa qui a donné donc le
judaïsme perd 10 pas elle qui a donné
disons le
l'islam enfin en un gros traits serait
né parce que c'est très très
controversée sur le plan archéologique
sur le plan biblique en tout cas la
tradition reconnaît cela donc au fond
aléas ou en chaldée c'est vraiment au
sud ces allait finalement à l'endroit où
final le monothéisme à aa pris corps et
a donné ensuite toute cette filiation et
abraham à qui était promis une filiation
digne du nombre d étoiles dans le ciel
enfin tout ça c'est très beau langage
qui aujourd'hui ses frères et ses fils
ses descendants se bat mais là c'est
justement en ce lieu symbolique
symbolique que le pape
françois comme avait voulu le faire jean
paul n'a pas pu le faire
veut délivrer un message de fraternité
d'espérance une sorte de pari un peu fou
mais je crois que dans cette période où
il faut rêver c'est le propre aussi d'un
message chrétien et spirituelle dire oui
l'accord est possible ou une entente est
possible entre croyants alors justement
dans cette lignée là je salue aride qui
nous disent sur youtube
hors irak ce jour est historique sans
aucun doute en tous les cas il y aura
une rencontre importante demain à nadjaf
on est en plein pays chiite et c'est
georges un des autres enjeux de la
rencontre que peuvent attendre les
chiites de cette visite
qu'est ce qu'ils en attendent déjà une
reconnaissance que le pape se déplace
pour aller voir la plus haute autorité
chiite l'ayatollah sistani qui à 90 ans
est un événement soit parce que si
staline ne reçoit jamais des chefs
d'état il reçoit que des autorités les
nations unies et donc voilà
les chiites en attendent une
reconnaissance parce que c'est la
première fois qu'un pape visite un pays
musulman à majorité chiite
aussi il était allé au caire il est allé
à abou dhabi la rencontre il a fait d'un
document homard au maroc
mais voilà donc les chiites qui sont la
branche minoritaire de l'islam à travers
ce voyage vont se sentir reconnus et le
je dirais le point d'orgue de cette
reconnaissance sera demain cette
rencontre entre deux autorités
spirituelles et elle insiste annick qui
est des grands ayatollahs de ce qu'on
appelle la marjaïya c'est à dire la
maison shit et face à lui donc le pape
qui va lui tendre la main et donc c'est
important parce que parce qu'il y avait
effectivement une une petite lacune que
le pape a souhaité combler et
symboliquement c'est très fort
dimanche direction le nord on va
regarder de nouveau la carte et
direction alors là ça va être une tout
autre ambiance ses directions mossoul la
plaine de deniv françois seront en fête
dont georges l'épicentre de ce qui fut
le territoire occupé par des chenilles
c'est quand même en soi rien que cette
présence et oui tout à fait et puis là
justement encore une fois à bagdad
capitale politique
restauration de l'état ensuite pour bon
symbole biblique nadjaf shit
ensuite il va dans le pays sunnites
mossoul c'est la grande ville sunnite
qui a été la capitale de neige neige qui
a fait subir les exactions au mossoul
iode dont une partie sont des chrétiens
qui ont dû fuir aussi mais non on a le
troisième axe est ensuite après il va
aller à erbil chez les kurdes donc c'est
yahia la fois un double message donc
bagdad la restauration de l'état central
et puis faire le tour de ces communautés
en leur disant et notamment aux
chrétiens et ils en sont convaincus
parce qu'ils espéraient beaucoup en 2003
les amis chrétiens à bagdad qui espérait
dans l'avènement de la démocratie la
liberté etc etc
ils sont ils sont revenus de leurs
illusions
est ce qu'il faut c'est un état fort qui
leur permettent justement d'être des
citoyens et non pas des soumis comme ils
l'ont été à mossoul
lorsque dèche gérait cette ville je
donne la parole jorge je donne la parole
jean marie mai ont justement j'en
reviens qu'on retrouve benoit camorra à
bagdad qui est encore à bagdad mais
justement vous
vous avez suivi vous ce qui s'est passé
dans cette région vous aviez vous aviez
alerter sur les familles chrétiennes qui
ont été obligés de fuir notamment la
nuit du 4 août 2014
on va raconter on va confier une
anecdote que si vous m'aviez appelé dans
la nuit justement pour alerter très dur
et et les médias est lancée à l'époque
pour 4 heures du matin pour nous
informer de cette situation est ce que
on imagine l'émotion des habitants de
cette ville de savoir ou de que là où
ils ont été obligés de fuir et bien
c'est le pape lui même qui va revenir
aujourd'hui est ce que c'est ça en tous
les cas qu'ils ressentent
oui avec le pape qui vient demain sur ce
lieu très symbolique cette cathédrale
notre dame elle tyra de mossoul qui est
très lourd on est allé avant des chais
qui est aujourd'hui détruite
le pape a prié pour tous les morts de la
guerre il a aussi lâché des colombes en
signe de paix ça va être un très bon
signe pour tous les irakiens
et effectivement avec le pape qui
revient au soul c'est aussi peut-être
une invitation parce que c'est difficile
il faut dire la vérité pour les
chrétiens de se réinstaller à mossoul
aujourd'hui il ya entre 50 et 70
familles qui se sont réinstallées
généralement elles ont été bien
accueillies par leurs voisins musulmans
mais c'est quand même un paquet
difficile les chrétiens se soient sentis
trahis par ces personnes qui ont rejoint
des chais qui les ont chassées de chez
elles en 2014
donc oui la venue du pape françoise il
souhaite une invitation ou pour les
chrétiens à se réapproprier leurs terres
à revenir chez eux
c'est le cas à qaraqosh dans la plaine
de ninive où il va aller ensuite mais ce
que je voudrais dit aussi à travers ce
voyage c'est que on se dit que là où va
le pape au fond les choses vont bien
mais c'est pas parce que le pape j'ai en
irak que il faut cesser de soutenir les
chrétiens d'irak
au contraire je crois que sa venue est
un appel au monde entier à continuer ce
soutien pour les chrétiens et pour les
autres minorités parce qu'ils sont dans
ce pays un ferment de dialogue d'unité
de pluralisme qui est un cadeau et un
service pour tout l'irak
où je me trouve cet hôpital saint
raphaël de bagdad eh bien il soigne tout
le monde quelle que soit sa religion
quelles que soient ses revenus et ses 1
services de santé essentiels pour tous
les gens de bagdad et s'est tenu par des
soeurs les chrétiens joue ce rôle au
service de tout le monde sans
distinction d'appartenance religieuse et
et c'est en cela que qu'elle est qui qui
que nous soyons chrétiens ou non
nous avons de vrais réseaux devraient de
voir une vraie responsabilité pour
soutenir cette communauté on va remettre
justement vous re signer comme on dit
dans le jargon et remettre et rappeler
que vous êtes directeur de d'une ong qui
s'appelle fraternité alors l'irak
vous vous faites quoi exactement
fra-ter-ni-té en irak aide les chrétiens
à revenir chez eux dans la plaine de
ninive en leur rachetant leurs outils de
travail par exemple en permettant aux
boulangers de racheter son matériel en
rachetant un cheptel à l'éleveur de
moutons en relançant un charpentier un
laveur de voitures donc l'enjeu c'est
vraiment de redonner du travail aux
familles sur la durée mais ça passe
aussi par des projets symbolique ça a
été la reconstruction du monastère de
mar bernard un lieu de pèlerinage
chrétien ou se rendent aussi les
musulmans et les yézidis qu'il a du 4e
siècle là pour le carême on invite nos
amis français à soutenir la paroisse
saint jean baptiste de qaraqosh pour
reconstruire son clocher et puis par
exemple ici à bagdad nous avons soutenu
les familles ouvrent de bagdad à travers
toutes les paroisses de bagdad à travers
une douzaine de paroisses qui ont
distribué à toutes ces familles touchées
par le coronavirus de la nourriture des
médicaments des produits d'hygiène et
puis là où je me trouve à cet hôpital
saint raphaël il ya des équipements
stratégiques
un scanner des endoscopes à la part aux
scop pour la santé de tous les irakiens
à travers l'action de ces chrétiens qui
sont engagés pour tous leurs frères donc
oui c'est des plus des projets certes un
petit d'autres un peu plus gros pour
lesquelles tous les spectateurs du
figaro lie je peux choisir de participer
ça des internats c'est pas grave nous en
voudront pas merci pour
elle n'a pas dans tous créent leur été
vous avez pu lancer leur appel
votre appel jean-marie merci benoît jean
marie justement sur ce retour des
chrétiens en irak
est-ce que d'abord le pape et le saint
siège soutient ce retour sur la terre
d'origine ou bien et est ce que est ce
que il commence à ce que ça commence à
se produire parce qu'il n'ya pas que les
rats qui concerne également et la syrie
à tout un pays
tout un tas de pays d'orient dont les
les chrétiens ont dit que le crédit de
l'extrême complexité parce que ce ce que
l'on sait des irakiens c'est l'intention
du pape dans ce voyage n'a l'intention
du pape n'est pas de dire aux chrétiens
qui sont partis revenez elle et de dire
chrétien qui reste est resté assumer ce
rôle
on l'a très bien vu avec l'intervention
de benoît camurat et est ce que l'on
disait avec avec georges
on hâte une l'irak c'est une mosaïque
une véritable mosaïque au fond les
chrétiens sur deux cols qui tient ce
peut tenir contribué à affaire que cette
pause et une tiennent ensemble et on
vient de nous expliquer l'action
sanitaire par l'hôpital mais on va
n'importe où dans toutes les universités
ou écoles ou proche orient george en
parlera mieux que moi les écoles cateau
ouvre grand large forme des élites
musulmanes julia c'est la tradition n'y
a aucune discussion nations les
chrétiens ont un rôle central
ils peuvent être minoritaires ils sont
minoritaires et le sable donc ne pas va
pas dire ton chrétiens du monde irakien
du monde chrétien on veut revenir et
qu'il va dire consolidons la place des
chrétiens en irak
au titre de la citoyenneté c'est un
débat plus juridique d'ailleurs que que
spirituelle même si là aussi des
ascendances c'est vraiment un débat
presque politique et à travers ça quand
les choses se seront stabilisées
peut-être que des petits enfants les
enfants reviendront en irak
mais le sujet n'est pas de défendre
absolument la présence au sens
communautaire des chrétiens en irak
juste une autre question qaraqosh qui
est très important par daniel koch effet
la petite ville de qaraqosh où il va
aller à yves allez donc à mossoul
qaraqosh ou que ville chrétienne qui
était beaucoup souffert et ensuite erbil
demain qaraqosh herman le symbole même
de la présence de la présence chrétienne
de présence dans cette région
il nous reste on a dépassé le temps d'un
parti juste répondre à cette question
d'internaute dont bestbuy qu'il faut
arrêter la persécution des chrétiens
dans l'orient je prie pour que cette
visite soit positive et kris kross nous
demande un voyage du pape en iran
serait-il possible et en russie en grèce
terre orthodoxe kke réponse monsieur
heroes georges sera mieux placé que moi
mais ça me paraît impossible
est ce que justement laissé ya des
chrétiens l'étape à nadjaf
elle va pas les rats l'iran parce que
l'ayatollah sistani le défenseur d'un
d'un chiisme irakien et pas d'un schisme
sous l'ombrelle de téhéran et donc c'est
relayent même s'il est né en iran
ses relations avec l'iran sont tendus
parce que lui il est il et il est il est
nationaliste il ira irak
justement alors la tactique du pape
c'est de mettre un pied dans schisme par
parra irak mais effectivement ce pas
d'illusions sur les rangs rue sinon
c'est pas l'ordre du jour parce que
c'est très compliqué avec les orthodoxes
les relations sont bonnes mais et et
pour des raisons politiques et pro des
raisons religieuses les temps ne sont
pas mûrs en revanche le grand dossier
vraiment préparation c'est la chine et
le pape est très discret sur la question
de hong kong
étonnamment discret parce qu'il prend la
défense de toutes les situations
humanitaires ou politique d'injustice
dans le monde mais il se tait sur hong
kong parce que ils envisagent comme
jésuites d'aller un jour à pékin
qu'est ce que vous allez gaieté
pendant cette visite georges laquelle se
passe bien déjà pour lui parce qu'il ya
quand même un risque d'attentât en
érable le savez vous n'êtes jamais sûr
de rien donc donc je pense qu'il faut
guetter déjà la sécurité du pape et de
sang et son entourage parce que parce
qu' un certain nombre de personnes qui
ne lui veulent pas du bien
moi le message parce que il ya il ya des
modulations dans ce message de
fraternité
ce message interreligieux qui est très
délicat notamment sur la question juive
on le pense bien avec les questions des
relations avec l'iran
donc c'est vraiment le contenu qui va
être très important est ce que le pape
va sortir de ce qu'il a déjà dit où est
ce que on ne sera dans dans la dans la
filiation
allez on va peut-être regarder des
images encore à bagdad mais c'est sûr ça
qu'on va se quitter merci beaucoup merci
également à benoît camurat qui était à
bagdad devant justement l'église tenu
par l'ordre dominicain sur place et qui
va suivre pendant tous
tout ce voyage les différentes étapes
qui vont être donc et
dans différentes étapes de ce voyage les
mots vont venir
merci beaucoup bien sûr le de l'arrivée
du pape en irak c'est l'événement à
retrouver sur le site du figaro dans
quelques minutes bien sûr et bien sûr à
suivre à vivre tout le week-end et vous
aurez tous les textes les infos de
jean-marie et les analyses de georges
est également les images qui seront
justement suivi des coupés et mises en
ligne par les équipes de filles are
alive
à très vite sur le figaro.fr dans un
instant le taux que florence portelli
est l'invitée d'yves trait à très vite
sur